Hi Michael.
>> Hi Charles, how are you?
>> I'm doing fine, thanks for
asking, how are you doing?
>> I'm doing well, I'm exciting to be
kind of pulling the course together and
wrapping it up and putting it in a box
and sending it out into the world.
>> Yes, me too,
it's actually been fun so far.
As we tape this we
are about halfway through,
I would say,
of the first iteration of the course.
And Michael kindly agreed to come
down Atlanta to talk to me again.
So that we could mention a few other
things that we didn't get a chance to
cover in the class, because we
basically just didn't have time.
It's not that they weren't interesting,
but because this was a survey kind of
course, we wanted to make
certain that you had the basics.
And that from there you could go off and
learn things and
really understand why
they're interesting.
So, what we're going to do is just very
quickly, talk about some of the things
that are either new and interesting now,
or perhaps old that we just didn't have
time to cover, although,
may still show up on the final exam.
>> [LAUGH] And plus,
I believe that everyone now has
a really good background for
being able to appreciate those things.
>> Right, I believe that's important.
The main goal of the course was to
give people enough of a breadth, and
just enough depth.
So that they can go out into the world
and understand why something like
deep neural networks are interesting or
different, or
the same, as the way we've been thinking
about these problems for years.
So maybe that's a good
one to start with.
So, maybe we can just talk about
some of the things we didn't cover.
So, there are two big things
that are popular right now.
Or that a lot of people
would have heard of.
>> Buzz words.
>> Buzz words but in a good way.
>> [LAUGH]
>> As opposed to just made up stuff.
Deep neural networks.
>> Okay. Sure. >> Or deep learning,
which I think is how most
people talk about it.
>> Deep learning.
Sure.
>> And big data.
So, those are two kind of
things that are out there
in 2014 that people talk about.
We didn't really get
a chance to mention,
how would you describe
them in 15 seconds?
>> So, big data is the issues that
come up when you actually have
a tremendous amount of data.
So more and more now it's possible
to attach sensors to the world and
get tremendous amount of information,
either web pages or biological data.
I've got a little thing that
measures my steps every day.
You start to pull this data off over
enough people, there's a tremendous
resource, but also challenges in
extracting good information from it.
>> Right.
And a lot of those challenges
are algorithmic.
We talk about things like
the curse of dimensionality and
now we deal with exponentially.
Well, when you have big enough data,
the truth is even linear can be slow.
Quadratic is unacceptable.
>> Linear in the amount of data.
>> Yeah, linear in the amount of data,
because you've got so
much data coming in.
And, by the way, you're never
going to be able to look at it again.
Because, by the time you look at
the first set of data, another day has
passed, and you've got another several
petabytes of data that are coming in.
What's really nice about big data,
which is worth mentioning,
I think,
without going into too much detail.
>> Yeah, it's only been 15 seconds.
So that's it.
>> Only been 15 seconds?
>> Yeah.
>> We got another 3 or 4,
is that [LAUGH] the data,
because we have access to all this data,
it's fundamentally changed
the way science works.
So it used to be people talked
about experiments and theory and
I'm sure there was something else,
about how science was done.
>> [LAUGH] Something else.
Like scientific method.
>> But
now one of the new pillars of science,
which is finally agreed upon by
the scientific community is Computation.
The ability to do simulation
the ability to look at the data in
order to validate models in a way
we couldn't do even 15 years ago.
And that's really amazing,
it's one of the reasons why my guess is
most of the people who are looking at
this first heard about machine learning.
It's one of the reasons why it's so
popular because it's applicable to these
big science problems that we care about.
Okay, what about deep learning?
>> Yeah, so Deep Learning or
Deep Neural Nets.
I think in some ways it's a reboot.
Is that a word that we use now?
>> Reboot is a world.
>> A prequel.
No, it's a reboot.
I'm going to go with reboot.
>> Okay.
Let's go with reboot.
>> Of neural nets, so back in the 80s,
there was this idea that you could
train up neural nets with
things like back prop.
But it was not so
clear that you could do better with
multiple layers than you could
with just a single layer.
Even though we know that brains are
organized into lots and lots of layers.
>> Right.
>> So it kind of fell out of favor for
while, but it's back.
And I think part of it is there's a new
set of techniques that can be used to
organize the computation in a way
that you can actually get valuable
information.
Signal, coming through at each of the
different layers of the Deep Neural Net.
>> Right.
Does it hold onto a clever
representational trick or
is there more to it than that?
>> I think there's a bunch
of different tricks.
And one of the reasons we
didn't talk about them,
is we don't really know them.
>> Yeah, and it would take too long.
And.
>> Yes, sorry.
It would take too long for
us to learn them.
>> Right.
>> Teach them.
>> Yeah to teach them.
It certainly would take too long,
because we understand them completely.
Okay.
>> We have deep neural nets.
>> We do.
Well, maybe we think we do.
I guess we got things to do.
Is that what we actually think we do?
Isn't there a biological plausibility.
I can't remember.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah, let's go with that.
Okay, so let's see.
What else haven't we covered that would
be, how about semi-supervised learning?
This is something that I really wish
we could have gotten into the class and
maybe in a later iteration of
this we'll find a way to work.
>> We can put it half way between
supervised and unsupervised.
>> Or we could stick it
in unsupervised learning,
like we did randomized optimization.
>> Yeah,
it kind of fleshes it out a little bit.
But anyway, the idea of semi-supervised
learning is really cool.
Like it's a slightly different problem.
It has elements of both supervised and
unsupervised.
>> Like what?
>> So, imagine for
example, that you've got
tons of web pages that have on
them information about cities.
>> Okay.
>> And
you label them, you say this webpage
has information about this city.
And this webpage has
information about this city.
And you eventually you get tired
of doing that because labeling is
human expensive.
>> Yes.
>> So if you've got a billion web pages
and you've only have time
to label a million of them,
then there's still
a factor of a thousand.
>> Sure let's go with that.
>> Yeah, of pages that you
have information on them but
there's no labels.
And so I think in the early days people
thought since we don't have labels,
there's no really valuable
information there.
The idea of semi supervised learning
is that you can actually extract using
unsupervised methods,
enough structure from the unlabeled data
that when combined with
the labelled data, its like
having the power of a lot more label
data than you actually started with.
>> Yeah, that was a big deal in
the late 80s, early 90s in particular.